hoy se podría hacer historia en la NBA
es un día muy emocionante para los que
amamos el deporte Ángela los Boston
celtas reciben a los Miami hit en El
séptimo partido de las finales de la
conferencia este el equipo de Joe
matsula viene de igualar una serie que
perdía por tres a cero los celtics
tienen la oportunidad hoy en el TD
Garden en su estadio de ser la primera
franquicia que supera esta desventaja en
una eliminatoria de playoffs de la NBA
al mejor de siete partidos es imposible
pedir más emoción el sábado en Miami en
Florida desperdició su tercera
oportunidad de sellar esta llave una
canasta agónica de derry White con menos
de un segundo juego con algunas décimas
en realidad le dio la victoria a los
sueltes para llevarnos al duelo de hoy
qué nos dicen las estadísticas en este
tipo de eliminatorias ahí tenemos que
fijarnos sí Ángela las estadísticas son
muy contundentes en la historia de la
NBA ha habido un total de 150
eliminatorias que han terminado siempre
a favor de los equipos que se han puesto
por delante 3 a 0 Ese es el peso en
contra que tiene Boston en este momento
Miami de otra parte se arriesga hacer el
primer equipo en romper con tal cifra de
otra parte Boston es la cuarta
franquicia que logra llegar a un séptimo
partido después de perder por 3 a 0 los
antecedentes son los New yorks en 1951
contra los Rochester Rogers en finales
los Royals hoy en día los Sacramento
Kings los Denver nuggets en 1994 contra
los tallas en segunda Ronda de playoff y
los Portland blazers en 2003 frente a
los Dallas Mavericks en primera ronda un
dato a tener en cuenta estos tres
equipos perdieron la eliminatoria como
visitantes hoy Boston es local hay algo
con Boston con las eliminatorias de tres
a cero en 2004 en las finales de las
grandes ligas de los medias rojas
remontaron un tres a cero adverso contra
los New York Yankees en esa final que
también era la primera vez que ocurría
algo así en béisbol vamos a ver si
Boston vuelve a tener esa magia ahora en
el balonces